chris hogan joining me this our ramsey
personality author of the number one
bestseller retire inspired and the new
book that the pre-sales have begun on
every day millionaires how ordinary
people build extraordinary wealth and
how you can do we're answering your
questions a triple eight eight two five
five two two five francs in new york
city
hi Frank how are you hi I'm fine how are
you
better than I deserve what's up in your
world I just have a two-part question
one is about a car lease that ending not
another is about my overall process of
trying to get debt-free now I think I
had partly an income problem because I
was partly living off of credit cards
using them to make ends meet so when I
was trying to pay off debt
I had to account for that and so I
started working a little extra and I'm
making a few hundred dollars extra every
two weeks but still the listening to you
for about ten months and still it's just
going very slow for me and what is your
income and then how much is that you got
extra income of about four hundred bucks
a month what's your main income so my
income is about two hundred and twenty
thousand a year okay that does not
equate to moving slow on that with me
dude I have I have one hundred and sixty
six thousand and and I think you include
I have a second on my house as include
that hundred sixty six thousand on what
do I have student loans of ninety six
thousand I have a credit card that's
fifty six thousand I have some personal
loans at fourteen thousand okay and you
keep saying I are you single no my wife
and I okay and your household income
that's two hundred thousand bucks plus
it's about 220 okay all right
so here's what's running through
everyone that's listening is mind where
is all this money going just have so
many payments I have like 25 more credit
cards and then you know alone for a HVAC
system all these loans so let's play
pretend if we're sewing out and it
stopped saying let's play pretend for a
second payments let's just say that you
lived on 150,000 dollars that would
cover your lifestyle your food shelter
clothing transportation and utilities
which is an awful lot to do that so I'm
being absurd it should be less than that
even in New York City yes I know what
New York City costs I'm there all the
time but let's just say that you took
you hundred fifty then that would leave
you 50 to throw at debt and not counting
interest in four years you would be debt
free so something's wrong in your budget
you guys are spending like you're in
Congress yeah we are spending you know
things do come up for example last week
we hadn't claimed to put my youngest boy
in football and then we decided to put
them in footballs that was a couple
hundred bucks two hundred dollars in
your problem man it's five thousand
dollars a month is your problem mmm
you're spending five thousand dollars a
month on stupid stuff that's $60,000 a
year Chris what are you seeing here
Frank are you all still using the credit
cards yeah is it you or your wife that's
using them me okay so you are the
spender no no you have to acknowledge
that you say you Frank you're the
spender and so what you have to do is
really have this mind shift you're
working way way too hard for all these
debts that's why you're not feeling any
progress and so what has to happen Dave
hit on it you got to look at your budget
and you got to get mad see right now
you're just irritated with that I want
you to get mad at
and really cut back your lifestyle and
say this changes today and watch what
happens but you've got to get together
you and your wife on the same page in
agreement a hundred percent ok dumb
people don't make two hundred twenty
thousand dollars a year so you're not
dumb so if I hired you and I said okay
Frank here's your side job I'm gonna pay
you a hundred thousand dollars a year
and I want you to go into this family
and I want you to get them out of that
and they make two hundred thousand
dollars a year and they have a hundred
sixty six thousand dollars and that you
would write do a detailed written plan
you would cut their life to the bone and
you would clean up their mess very very
quickly because that's the only way
you're getting your hundred grand as a
consultant I'm not gonna pay you if you
don't get them out of that and so you're
smart enough to do this you know
mechanically tactically what to do
you're spiritually and emotionally and
relationally with your wife have got to
commit to doing it that's what Chris is
talking about the anger and you got to
reach a point where you're not saying
well this is inconvenient instead you're
going out that's when you change your
life and we've seen that Chris for years
we really have Dave and I'm talking
about people that aren't making anywhere
near this kind of income I'm talking of
the single mom that I remember sitting
with that was making 30 grand I'm
talking about you know the single guy
that had 48,000 and credit card debt but
he was making 70 and he didn't go to a
restaurant he ate ramen noodles and
peanut butter matter of fact he twitched
when he saw peanut butter and he got out
of debt he ate it so much I don't which
one that's a tuna fish yeah I don't I
don't say the word Dave I hate to allow
you to but the thing is is you have to
Frank make a decision for yourself are
you gonna keep making these credit card
companies rich and the personal owns
companies rich are you gonna start to do
the thing that I think you want to do
deep down in your heart and that's build
a legacy for you your wife and your
children
it's your decision here's your test this
is a test of the emergency Frank
financial system here's the test sit
down with your wife tonight with every
dollar and do a detailed written plan
and cut up every credit card if you
don't do that tonight I can't help you
mmm get the scissors out it's time for
plastic surgery dude
you are in desperate need of a plus
ectomy because you've been limping along
long enough it's you've got a radical
mess that's going to require a radical
solution